I'm one red Bergdorf I am a model and
activist and I'm Emma Gannon I'm an
author broadcaster podcast host and
we're here to talk about feminism so I
think for me the most simple definition
of feminism is equal opportunity and
choice but not necessarily expecting
women or men to make particular
decisions for example not all women want
to be a CEO but they should have the
opportunity to be one they want to the
dictionary definition is equality
between the sexes I think it needs to be
broadened towards equality between
identities when I think of feminism I do
you think of like my personal feminism I
think of my feminist activism
I think the activism can be as small or
large as you can manage and no one
should feel like they should ever need
to be an activist if it's going to be
detrimental to your safety then don't do
it
but if it's something that you feel you
can do to help yourself than others then
the other thing I think you could do
just to feel like you're maybe part of
something is celebrating other women in
small ways I don't think feminism is
liking all women there's loads of them
and I don't like that's okay but I think
by just like retweeting someone's
campaign or I don't know following
someone who is like really different to
you and just like lifting other women up
in a way that's just like small acts of
lifting up others sure
so I'm obsessed with the slum flower oh
my god I'm obsessed - she's amazing I
really feel like she's like a diamond in
the rough I love that her hashtag is is
taking off taking her saggy boobs matha
oh my god yes yes love what like a
national attention and it's just a
hashtag on Instagram I think that's
what's exciting right now as well it's a
different take on body positivity isn't
it not really talking about and cardi B
obviously Isis very accidental the
feminist icon there's this Guardian
article written by an amazing poet with
Brigitte Minnie more and it's called can
I be a feminist and mm-hmm and I think
the answer is always yes
whatever that and is it's always a yes
within that need to be well it's
to each other you know like can I be a
feminist and wear pink
can I be a feminist and wear makeup
gonna be a feminist and not have
children like what do you think there's
some sort of blurred lines with so for
example I freaked out the other day
because I was a spider in my house I
hate spiders and I made my boyfriend get
rid of the spider is that not feminine
like that you know small things like
that I do question myself and just and
we were talking about chivalry recently
yeah like is it
unfeminist to want someone to open a
door for you yeah I do get that guilty
feminist thing sometimes I guess there's
always that social construct that we've
like learn and then there's you know
that process of unlearning and then
existing between the tooth I know so
many nice well-intentioned men in my
life who still don't understand what
feminism means they still find it
slightly aggressive the term if I go
into a room and say yeah I'm a feminist
I know a lot of people as well he prefer
the word humanist but I think it's
missing the point because we need the
femme in there to scare the prey for the
point
feminism is still thought it's for
everybody it benefits everybody so when
we just like turn off and say humanist I
think it's just getting away from the
issue what really really annoys me is
women in the public eye that I really
respect when they just say well I
wouldn't call myself a feminist and just
like you've got an opportunity to use
your platform and it literally just
means equality of the sexes how can you
not be a feminist absolutely everybody
should be a feminist I so agree because
by saying I'm a FEMINIST even the people
who aren't sure will then go and look it
up and then they'll read what it
actually means there's the common
misconception that men don't benefit
from feminism that men have anything to
contribute which is ridiculous when the
definition is equality and equality
means that neither can be in charge of
either and the reality is that men
dominate is so much a society in a way
that oppresses women I think that if a
man isn't 100% secure within himself and
with his gender identity
what his identity means within the
construct that is masculinity then I can
understand how you can find a woman
that's comfortable within her identity
it earns and how you can find that quite
threatening I totally agree if one thing
I've been thinking recently about this
of defensiveness when it comes to men I
realized that a lot of the feminists
sort of debates or events even private
Facebook groups like all of this stuff
they do all include a lot of women I
feel like I need to include men more in
the feminism dialogue and I don't blame
some men not all men for feeling
slightly left out and actually I feel
like it's up to us as feminists to you
know group hug everyone in yeah I do
feel like misandry
which is the opposite to misogyny I mean
that's just going to have such
detrimental effects
I think the feminism does need to be
inclusive and there needs to be a
narrative that is inclusive of men but
men also need to understand that
feminism is to largely liberate women is
not to liberate men forever mm-hmm for
me my perspective on global feminism is
i-i've struggled with actually over the
past because I've always felt like I'm a
privileged white woman on a panel
talking about a pay gap in London like
that's never made me feel like I'm doing
that much in the massive wider scheme of
things but there's a quote I read a
while ago I can't remember who said it
but they said that feminism is like a
patchwork quilt of like you doing your
bit I'm just great believer that there's
no leader in feminism they cannot just
be one person that's looting the park
and I feel like that's where I've become
uncomfortable when people refer to
themselves as leaders of feminism I feel
like every person is leading their own
personal journey and when it comes to
global feminism I completely agree
I can't speak on what it's like to be
you know a trans woman in Indonesia and
what her feminist battle is I think it's
all about passing the mic and using
whatever platform we have as privileged
people within the Western world to give
that person the microphone
and say this is your chance to tell your
story not me tell your story for you I
think it's interesting with people who
don't follow this trend of wearing black
for example on the red carpet so at the
BAFTAs recently Frances McDormand
decided not to but she made a joke about
it on stage that she wasn't good at
compliance and that she'd worn a red
dress and people laughed and people
loved her so she got away with it it's
fine Kate Middleton wore a green dress
and everyone was like up in arms and I
were all the protocol
yeah apparently she can't wear she can't
be political is that so she wore like
the closest darkest color why do you
think people have rules for some women
and rules for different women and what
this is there I think it's society finds
women threatening or they're not
particularly lovable woman or the
nation's sweetheart
then I don't know the sense of I don't
really want to be on your side I also
feel like there's a trend of really
lifting up people and then tearing them
back down oh my god like on the flip
side of any successful women any there's
always been backlash for anybody that
calls out women for being feminists or
shames or feminist misogyny mm-hmm I
always think of it as though whenever I
write an article that might be slightly
controversial because I've said I'm a
feminist in it I get these like trolls
that come out and I think of it as like
stranger things you know like the upside
down I go into this like Twitter world
but I didn't know ever existed and
they've all got like the same profile
picture like waving a flag or something
and I'm just thinking oh my god there's
so many of you they exist but don't like
feminists but then I think also forcing
all of these people off of social media
is just creating a new platform where it
will just breathe that kind of may I
think that there needs to be a balance
it's difficult because there's a big
difference between using your freedom of
speech and abusing your freedom of
speech and I don't think that a lot of
people understand
difference I mean if I'm being honest
the future of feminism to me is we don't
talk about it I think feminism is one
when we don't make videos about feminism
do you know what I mean like talking
about feminism is really important right
now because I think we can get lazy we
can get complacent we can think yay
time's up
it's all fixed whereas feminism is still
very much needed but I think I'd love it
for it not even to be a word the fact
that the world is equal
thank you for watching hey it's okay if
you enjoyed our conversation then
subscribe to Kalama UK's YouTube channel
and comment below and for more
information on feminism check the
description box down below